ميدانيا قالت كتائب القسام ان مقاتليها
تمكنوا من استهداف قوه اسرائيليه متحصنه
في منزل بقذيفه مضاده للافراد وايقاعها
بين قتيل وجريح وذلك غرب مدينه خانيونس
جنوب قطاع غزه كما استهدفوا دبابتين
ميركافا اسرائيليتين بقذيفه الياسين 105
غرب مدينه خانيونس جنوب قطاع غزه
واستهدفوا دبابتين ميركافا اسرائيليتين
بقذيفه الياسين 105 غرب مدينه خان يونس
جنوب قطاع غزه وفي منطقه الشيخ عجلين جنوب
غرب مدينه غزه اشتبك مقاتل القسام مع قوه
اسرائيليه راجله مكونه من ثمانيه جنود
واوقع بين قتيل وجريح وفي غرب مخيم
المغازي تم استدراج قوه اسرائيليه قوامها
سبعه جنود الى كمين وتفجير نفق فيهم كما
استهدفوا دبابت ميركافا بعبوه شواظ وقذيفة
المغازي استهدف مقاتل القسام دبابه
ميركافا وجراف من طراز 9 دي بقذائف
الياسين 105
والتند